my name is Cheri Davis and let's be
honest I'm a recovering government
employee and I say that with a huge
shout-out to the folks that work in
government and on systems change it's
hard it can be isolating and the work
can feel impossible but government is
the people that show up really it's the
people that can show up and are
committed to the promise that public
service offers service to people
democracy and fixing the problems that
community members face seventeen years
ago I walked through City Hall for the
first time as a staff member and that
walk revealed something to me I was a
unicorn there were many people who look
like me that worked in the building and
yet there were folks committed to
addressing hundreds of years of systemic
inequity that left some behind and many
ignored where there was promise there
was a huge problem
you see democracy as it was originally
designed had a fatal flaw it only laid
pipeline for rich white men to progress
and now if you're a smart rich white man
you understand what I say that's a
problem massive talent has been left off
the field our moral imaginations have
grown anemic our highest offices are
plagued by corruption we're on the brink
of a sort of apathetic apocalypse and
it's not okay we've got to open the
doors to City Hall's in schools so wide
that people can't help but walk in we've
got to throw out the old top-down
processes I got us into this mess and
start over with new faces around the
table new voices in the mix and we have
to welcome new perspectives every step
of the way not because it's the right
thing to do although it is but because
that's the only way
for us to all succeed together and
here's the best news of all I know how
to do it to answer well and answer is
participatory budgeting that's right
participatory budgeting or PB for short
PB is a process that brings community
and government together to ITA develop
concrete proposals and vote on projects
that solve real problems in community
now I realize that people don't get up
and dance when I start talking about
public budgets but participatory
budgeting is actually about collective
radical imagination everyone has a role
to play in PB and it works because it
allows community members to craft real
solutions to real problems and provides
the infrastructure for the promise of
government and honestly it's how I saw
democracy actually work for the first
time I remember it like it was yesterday
it was 2014 in Boston Massachusetts and
Mayor Menino asked me to launch the
country's first youth focus PB effort
with 1 million dollars of city funds now
we didn't start with line items and
limits or spreadsheets and formulas we
started with people we wanted to make
sure that everyone was listened to so we
brought in young people from
historically and traditionally
marginalized neighborhoods members of
the queer community and youth that were
formerly incarcerated and together often
with pizza and a sugar-free beverage we
talked about how to make Boston better
and we designed a process that we called
youth lead to change we imagined a
Boston where young people could access
the information that they need to thrive
where they could feel safe in their
communities and where they can transform
public spaces and to real hubs of life
for all people and that's exactly what
they did in the first year young people
allocated 90 thousand dollars to
increase tech
Knology access for boston public high
school students by delivering laptops
right to Boston public high schools so
that students could thrive inside and
outside of the classroom they allocated
sixty thousand dollars to creating art
walls that literally and figuratively
brightened up public spaces but they
addressed a more important problem young
people were being criminalized and
pulled into the justice system for
putting their art on walls so this gave
him a safe space to practice their craft
they allocated four hundred thousand
dollars to renovating parts to make them
more accessible for all people of all
bodies now admittedly this didn't go as
smoothly as we had planned
right before we broke ground on the park
we actually found out that it was on top
of an archeological site and had to halt
construction I thought I broke TV but
because the city was so committed to the
project that's not what happened they
invited community in to do a dig
protected the site found artifacts
extended Boston's history and then move
forward with the renovation as that
isn't a reflection of radical
imagination and government I don't know
what is what sounds simple is actually
transformational for the people and
communities involved I'm seeing
community members shape transportation
access improve their schools and even
transform government buildings so that
there's space inside of them for them
before we had PB I would see people who
look like me and come from where I come
from walk into government buildings for
this new initiative or that new working
group and then I watch them walk right
back out sometimes I wouldn't see him
again it's because their expertise was
being unvalued they weren't truly being
engaged in the process but PB is
different we started doing PB I met
amazing
young leaders across the city one in
particular a rock star malachi hernandez
15 years old came into a community
meeting shy curious a little quiet stuck
around and became one of the young
people hoping to lead the project now
fast forward a couple years malachi was
the first in his family to attend
college a couple weeks ago he was the
first in his family to graduate malachi
has appeared in the obama white house
several times as part of the my
brother's keeper initiative president
obama even quotes malachi and interviews
it's true you can look it up Malachi got
engaged stayed engaged and is out here
changing the way we think about
community leadership and potential or my
friend Maria had it who was involved in
the first PB process in Chicago then
went on to become a founding
participatory budgeting project board
member eventually a staff member and
then unseated a 28-year incumbent
becoming the first queer black alder
person in Chicago's history
that's real engagement that's being
taken seriously that's building out and
building on community leadership that's
system change and it's not just in the
u.s. either after starting 30 years ago
in Brazil PB has spread to over 7,000
cities across the globe and Paris France
the mayor puts up five percent of her
budget over a hundred million euros for
community members to decide on and shape
their city globally PB has been shown to
improve public health reduce corruption
and increase trust in government now we
know the challenges that we face in
today's society how can we expect people
to feel motivated to show up to the
polls when they can't trust that
government has run by and for the people
I'd argue that we
haven't actually experienced true
participatory democracy in these United
States of America just yet
but democracy is a living breathing
thing and it's still our birthright it's
time to renew trust and that's not going
to come easy we have to build new ways
of thinking of talking of working of
dreaming of planning in its place what
would America look like if everyone had
a seat at the table if we took the time
to reimagine what's possible and then
ask how do we get there
my favorite author Octavia Butler says
it best
I'm parable of the sower basically my
Bible she says all that you touch you
change all that you change changes you
the only lasting truth is change God is
change it's time for these 50 states to
change what got us here sure as hell
won't get us there we've got to kick the
walls of power down and plant gardens of
genuine democracy in their place that's
how we change systems by opening doors
so wide that people can't help but walk
in so what's stopping you from bringing
participatory budgeting to your
community
[Music]